Il y a un an, une équipe d'astrophysiciens publiait
la toute première photographie d'un trou noir.
Un événement exceptionnel ! Jusque là,
ils ne disposaient que de simulations.
Alors que là, il s'agit d'une véritable photographie
du trou noir.
M87, c'est le nom de l'objet, se trouve
à 55 millions d'années-lumière de la terre.
C'est loin ! Mais il vaut mieux...
Regardez cette pomme. Si je lâche, elle tombe.
C'est à cause de la gravitation universelle.
Dans l'univers, tous les corps s'attirent mais plus la masse est importante plus la gravitation est importante.
C'est pourquoi la pomme va
vers la terre et non l'inverse.
Ce trou noir est si massif, 6,5 milliards
de fois la masse du soleil, qu'il attire vers lui
tout ce qui se trouve dans les parages.
Y compris sa propre lumière qui ne parvient pas
à s'échapper et qui reste confinée.
Voilà pourquoi on parle de trou noir
même cette "capsule de déconfiné" n'y resterais pas.
Allez à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette "capsule de déconfiné"
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne pas les rater,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...